avez-vous des plans pour le dîner
ce soir, nous participerons à un repas liquide alors
que nous remontons le Golden
Mile en commençant par une
chope inaugurale dans le premier message puis sur le
vieux familier le célèbre coq la croix
remet le bon  compagnons le fidèle
serviteur le chien à deux têtes la sirène
la ruche la tête du roi et le trou
dans le mur pour une mesure de la même
chose avant la dernière pinte douce-amère dans
ce terminus le plus fatidique de la fin du monde
laissez une lumière sur la bonne dame pour
bien que nous  peut revenir avec une étincelle dans
nos yeux, nous serons en vérité ivres aveugles